so the pictures you just saw are
shocking they're also real so they can't
be ignored in the coming days you'll
hear what's happening at the border
described as a humanitarian crisis that
means the migrants are suffering and
they definitely are suffering and that's
sad but what's sadder is that americans
are suffering too
open borders have caused a deadly crisis
among the very people our government
supposedly exists to protect
close to a hundred thousand americans
have died of drug overdoses in the last
year these are not 85 year olds with
emphysema in nursing homes these are
kids on your street
young people in the prime of life our
country's future the next generation and
they are dead now mostly because of
fentanyl that came up through mexico
so open borders means much more of this
poison in your neighborhood killing our
children
statistics released this week show that
as of the end of july fentanyl seizures
at the southern border are more than
double what they were for all of last
year
joe biden did that
open borders mean many more young
americans will die again joe biden did
that neither he nor anyone around him
cares however
if a hundred thousand afghan refugees
died this year of anything what would be
talking about that and only that cnn
would do a special every week what
happened to the afghan refugees that
would be the single biggest issue in
this country by far
but a hundred thousand american young
people joe biden never even mentions it
he doesn't care
and drugs are hardly the only disastrous
effect of open borders the median price
of a new home in this country is now
almost six times higher than the median
american household income think about
that that's a record it's never happened
it's never been more expensive than it
is now to buy a house
if you're a young person who's hoping to
start a life in this country that is a
disaster so why is it happening lots of
reasons fed policy for one
but one of the reasons is overcrowding
it's that simple supply and demand
no one ever mentions it but since 1990
this country has gained about a hundred
million people 100 million 1990 doesn't
seem like that long ago to some of us
thanks to the lunatics now in charge
this
unsustainable growth is accelerating in
ways it never has before ever
under joe biden hundreds of thousands of
immigrants are coming into the united
states every single month so where are
they going to live exactly where are
they going to send their children to
school what about the health care
they've been promised for free
have you been to a hospital emergency
room recently you should go check it out
once you see it you'll understand the
future the democratic party is planning
for you squalid overcrowded chaotic loud
of course having created this human
disaster democrats now claim they have a
solution to it of course that's why they
created it in the first place so they
could fix it what's their solution
amnesty for eight million that's what
they proposed and they may very well get
it republicans are allowing this by and
large
that amnesty you should know would
apparently extend even to violent
criminals and gang members but wait a
second you may be asking i'm an american
how is allowing ms-13 to choose my
government to vote in my elections going
to make my life better what's in it for
me
well here's zoe lofgren of california to
explain
this amendment is very simple it
requires uh that aliens not receive
amnesty if they are a gang member i must
opposed this amendment
as
was mentioned before
the effect
of the
amendment would really be to frustrate
the legislative
recommendations that are an investment
in human infrastructure the united
states will benefit from the resulting
economic gains really for decades to
come
this amendment would dilute that
investment and diminish those economic
benefits and that alone isn't enough to
oppose this amendment
oh the economic gains from inviting
millions more people who don't have high
school diplomas into the country nothing
against those people
but does any adult really foresee a
future in this country where low skilled
labor
is the engine of economic growth that's
insane in fact it's a lie shocking even
by washington standards the bite
administration's plan will ultimately
entitle illegal immigrants to the full
benefits of citizenship that's the whole
point that would include medicaid social
security food stamps etc etc etc even as
the welfare state expands the number of
people drawing from it expands as well
how's that going to end
the cost of all of this according to the
congressional budget office will be in
the hundreds of billions of dollars in
the next few years alone
what about long term some estimates put
the cost at well over a trillion dollars
or more
but that's all justified according to
zoe lofgren because it's human
infrastructure
human infrastructure
that's weird humans are not
infrastructure humans are alive they
have souls there's a difference between
people and sewage systems
but not in the eyes of dem of the
democratic party there's really not that
much difference
they don't care about individuals
individuals are expendable
that's the mindset of every
revolutionary through history people are
a means
to power
so to our leaders illegal immigrants
have a very specific functional purpose
they are a tool to change the country
forever and ensure permanent democratic
control over our government they look at
the numbers if you were born in this
country and you don't have a high school
degree you're not voting for them you
don't like what they're doing they don't
want to change your mind they can't be
bothered they're going to bring in new
people without high school degrees got
it
it's changing the country in order to
win elections
so if this passes millions people who
came to this country illegally who by
definition don't care about our laws or
law and order that's why those people
from january 6 are still in solitary
confinement because they didn't believe
in law and order
but the people who care so deeply about
law and order are well picking millions
who clearly don't buy our system because
they're breaking our laws the day they
get here
the only point of this
is to make the democratic party more
powerful that's why it's not simply zoe
lofgren who's talking about human
infrastructure the bide administration
is talking about it too so is jerry
nadler
he chairs the house judiciary committee
strikes the entire immigration title
and the important investments in our
human infrastructure that it makes
therefore i urge opposition to the
amendment
yes if if the
chairman would
indulge me i'd like to know if he just
used the term human infrastructure
to refer to the portion of the bill that
mr gomer seeks to strike with his
amendment i did
so illegal immigration is now human
infrastructure
i
i don't know what to say
that was congressman thomas massey and
he's absolutely right
and it's true and obvious to anyone who
actually reads the amnesty bill
under the biden administration's plan
several categories of illegal aliens
will get green cards meaning they'll be
allowed to live in this country and
eventually get full citizenship and be
allowed to vote for democrats
one of the groups that will receive
green cards includes quote essential
workers this at a time when we've got an
employment crisis but what are essential
workers exactly what turns out according
to the democrats in congress pretty much
every worker is an essential worker
illegal migrants working in agriculture
which is overwhelmingly mechanized now
by the way health care food construction
transportation are all included they can
stay here indefinitely
so can illegal migrants that the bite
administration refers to as dreamers
that sounds like a relic from the obama
years no it includes any illegal
immigrant who entered this country prior
to this year under the age of 18. this
is insane let's just say it
to prove how insane it is congressman
mike johnson of louisiana tried to
introduce an amendment that would ban
illegal migrants who have multiple duis
from getting amnesty remember we used to
be against drunk driving not anymore
that was rejected too
let's make sure that if you have a
serial offender someone who
repeatedly is convicted of driving under
the influence that at least that
will prevent them from being given
amnesty
i urge all my colleagues to at least
support this amendment and i yield back
whether someone has two or six or 10 or
20
convictions of dui uh 30 years ago
someone could can can change that's why
we have the waiver provision you may
have any number of convictions for dui
because you're drunk
because you're an alcoholic
but you also
may cease to be an alcoholic and we all
know people or at least i know people
i'm sure many of us know people
who uh
are no longer alcoholics and ought to be
able to um
and not to be able to to to
to enjoy the benefits of the law
yeah
so they suddenly have deep compassion
for people struggling with chemical
dependence that's why they shut down the
country's aaa meetings for the last year
what do you think the effect of that was
that's why they completely ignored
nearly a hundred thousand americans dead
of drug ods they don't care at all
but you hear the compassion in jerry
nadler's voice he's got real compassion
for serial criminal offenders
as long as they're coming here illegally
he does not have compassion for you so
the minute that you break the law that
jerry nadler and the democratic party
would like to enforce the ones where
they tell you what you can do with your
own body what job you can have which you
can say in public
then you're not human infrastructure
you're a criminal
here's the senate majority leader
explain that we need a crackdown at the
border not because illegal aliens are
flooding into this country many using
fake documents no the real problem
according to chuck schumer is that we
have fake vaccine cards not fentanyl
fake vaccine cards coming from mexico
that's the real threat
and the problem is this
fake covet cards and they're coming in
large amounts in large bunches through
ports of entry is this an epidemic right
now no
could it become one absolutely if the
authorities do nothing about it so we
have to nip it in the bud our border
patrol our customs and our fbi can go
all out with inspections and confiscate
any of these cards as they come and they
are mailed here so today
i am urging a federal crackdown
on these counterfeit copied cards
a federal crackdown
there's more fentanyl coming over our
border killing americans across the
american citizens born here than ever
before in history mexico is the middle
of a drug war the zetas ms-13 from
central america all coming up here
chuck schumer doesn't care
but counterfeit vaccine cards that might
allow people to get around insane
vaccine mandates which are immoral and
unconstitutional no
those people need to go to prison that'd
be very bad for america's health
it's totally completely nuts
meanwhile the same people that are
telling you that we need to allow felons
from central america including gang
members and people with 20 dui arrests
to flood into this country
we need to make these people new
citizens they know it's dangerous
more dangerous than covet but they're
doing it anyway
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else